How do you find for
the outsourcing vendors.
That's one million dollar question.
It's so hard to find them.
It's even harder than hiring,
because basically,
you are interested in finding someone
that will do the job that you need to do
right now in a cheaper price but
hopefully in a better quality.
And this is hard.
And a lot of off showing
professional are still
struggling with finding
the perfect vendor.
Because you need the job to be perfect,
or at least like in very good standards.
You need them to be there for
you at all times, to be responsive.
You need them to be aware of costs.
You need them to be cost effective.
And you need them to really work with
you, and share the culture with you.
And finding this perfect fit for
the long term can be very challenging.
And the best ways to find an outsourcer
is [INAUDIBLE] to the best ways to
find a new employee or a new partner.
You're going to your friends,
to your colleagues,
to people you value their opinion.
And you're asking them,
who do you work with?
When did you have a good
experience with an outsourcer?
You're going to events and
you're trying to find professionals
that are the similar to you,
that are using outsourcing services.
Or you're getting lucky basically.
You're working with Elance or oDesk and
you're trying to in you're
starting to test them.
You're doing a lot of professional
exams, grace periods, you basically
testing the waters and then eventually
choosing one and that that's what I did.
I worked with a lot of outsourcing
companies along the years.
And about a year ago,
I found an outsourcing company
that now I can call my partners.
And I'm working with them
like they were in my team.
It's about twelve people.
We're doing a lot of stuff every day.